the United States is an extremely
militaristic culture right now and we
are armed to the teeth and we are very
aggressive and pursuing our interests
violently around the world until
recently we're in two major armed
conflicts we just withdrew our troops
from Iraq that's a very good thing I
hope we don't go back in and we still
have troops in Afghanistan Barack Obama
has pledged to bring those tubes home
our military is also gigantic it more
than doubled since 9/11 and there are no
signs that it's going to be reduced
appreciably any time in the future
Barack Obama has talked about maybe a
10% reduction over the next eight or ten
years which is which is trivial compared
to how big our budget really is the
United States military budget is roughly
the size of all other nations military
budgets combined if we cut our military
in half just in terms of the annual
defense budget it would still be much
bigger than China's and Russia's
combined I think I'd like to also see us
take the lead in getting rid of our
nuclear arsenal there is absolutely no
use for nuclear weapons anymore and it's
very difficult for us to make the case
to a country like Iran no you're not
allowed to have nuclear weapons well we
still have about 8,000 nuclear warheads
in our own arsenal I think it's hard for
us to tell other people that they should
respect the rule of law when we are
carrying out these illegal
assassinations in other places and are
answerable only to ourselves I think
that our militarism helps to perpetuate
the kind of fear and insecurity around
the world that unfortunately will make
conflict more likely I think our hope of
course is that other people are too
scared ever to engage in any sort of
violence or we will retaliate I don't
think it's going to work out work that
way so I see this period as an enormous
opportunity for our country for the
United States to show show some real
leadership because we are so powerful
and and we of course like to think of
ourselves as a peaceful just very moral
people and I think we have a right to
feel that about ourselves so I'm hoping
that we have the kind of leadership some
day maybe even Barack Obama in his
second term that will will seize this
opportunity and help convince Americans
and the rest of the world that now is a
time when we can really move past this
this period of militarism and war and
take those resources and use them to
solve some of the other problems that
often lead to conflict